oui très important surtout pour une
femme ou au soleil couleur caramel
parce que c'est un peu plus sexy le
teint doré à la côte depuis le début du
20e siècle
l'été chaud très chaud
l'écart à deux pas rôtir au soleil avec
le soleil pansement mais ça ressemble
plutôt à une salade de viande une salade
de viande ces corps est allé au soleil
avec dès les années 60 un petit
assaisonnements on vient de la mettre au
point sous forme d'un produit solaire
qui contient de l'huile de coprah
additionner des frais d'un fleurs
exotiques et voici la recette pour un
parfait coup de soleil
pourtant des gens 1960 le danger était
identifié les rayons du soleil sont
excellents pour l'organisme mais il faut
en user progressivement et avec mesure
n'essayez pas de faire disparaître trop
vite votre belle couleur aspirine
d'hommes blancs et autour des médecins
de mettre en garde dans les années 70
beaucoup de cancers cutanés ce sens les
velopper par une exposition trop
fréquentes pro répété au soleil mieux
faut se protéger avec des vêtements un
parasol ou une protection solaire
d'autant que la toute première crème en
france date de 1936 année de création
des congés payés la grande folie à
saint-trop' se tartiner pour se protéger
des patients tués tant que la goutte
d'or progressivement chez mon âge nous
permet de ne défendre correctement
contre le soleil mais chez bronzage on
n'obtient pas avant une dizaine de jours
quel que soit le produit non ployer une
peau caramel
oui mais pas une vieille peau
l'exposition au soleil peut abîmer
l'épiderme ou entraîner des brûlures
chaque année 50 à 70% des cancers
cutanés sont dues au soleil
[Musique]